[Musik]
breaking news
ja es ist die nachricht des tages bisher
nach 20 staffeln und bohlen comeback
jetzt das aus für dsds und das obwohl
rtl dieter bohlen ja erst zurückgeholt
hat ein jahr nachdem sich der sender von
ihm getrennt hat und damals hieß es noch
zu bild das war es mit der beziehung
bohlen und rtl komplett jetzt der große
schock für alle fans trotz bohlen
comeback wird dsds abgesetzt im
kommenden jahr wird deutschland sucht
den superstar 20 jahre alt doch die
jubiläumsstaffel die wird zwar
stattfinden aber zugleich auch die
letzte sein zum großen finale holt rtl
dieter bohlen also noch einmal zurück
als juror um mit allen fans die größten
talente in deutschland und die musik in
mitreißenden shows für die ganze familie
zu feiern das hat rtl heute morgen
verkündet
erst mal geht es weiter und auch in der
jubiläumsstaffel wird es für die
kandidaten sicher nochmal hart werden
denn wir wissen ja wer vor den poptitan
tritt der braucht ein dickes fell ja das
wissen vor allem die die es selbst
erlebt haben seine opfer und seine
lieblinge die ist es ohne dieter bohlen
ist mal ganz im ernst ist doch
eigentlich so ein bisschen wie pommes
ohne marios nagetier ohne parmesan das
hat nicht gepasst also ich freue mich
sehr dass die da
und für mich ist auf jeden fall wieder
ein grund halten ich find's cool und
sehr sehr schön dass er wieder zurück
ist ich denke die kandidaten werden auch
den gleichen täter erleben den ich
damals auch kennenlernen durfte der sich
für die kandidaten einsetzt der immer
einen lockeren spruch auf den lippen hat
es ist halt dieter bohlen mehr kann man
ja gar nicht dazu sagen und ich drücke
die daumen und wünsche ihm dass es genau
so schön wird vielleicht sogar noch ein
bisschen schöner in den vergangenen
jahren ja was geht ab dieter bohlen
endlich bist du wieder weil dies das
zurück weil ohne dich ist wie wenn du
keine und es ist heutzutage deswegen
besser die unterhose bleiben an und
deswegen braucht man optisch denn der
checker vom neckar da freut sich für
dich du weißt ich war langjähriger gast
bei dir vielleicht komme ich wieder wenn
ich wieder die chance bekomme ab 30
natürlich erzeugt ist
es erst her kommen sie hat auf jeden
fall
ich denke es wieder hat sich nicht
verändert und wenn immer der gleiche
meinung haben ob er war so zehn jahre
oder ein jahren immer meine meinung
haben der wird seine kommentaren sorgsam
habe immer da haben wir immer so sah
mich ja das comeback von dieter zu dsds
jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig überrascht
hier nicht zugeben es gab genau zwei
möglichkeiten die quoten nach der
letzten staffel noch mal irgendwie zu
retten und es wäre erstens gewesen das
format komplett einzustampfen und sich
etwas neues einfallen zu lassen oder auf
altbewährtes zurückgreifen man hat sich
offensichtlich für letzteres entschieden
war es natürlich jetzt nicht der
konsequenteste weg vom sender ist weil
es gab ja damals offensichtlich
berechtigte gründe für den weggang von
dieter von dsds und ich will jetzt
wahnsinnig gespannt wie es in der
kommenden staffel wird ich drücke auf
jeden fall einen kandidaten von herzen
die daumen dieter perlen wieder zurück
bei dsds dann wie ganz ehrlich sind was
ist auch dsds ohne dieter bohlen ich
denke jetzt mal zurück ist kann die
einschaltquoten wieder ganz nach oben
kriechen die kandidaten sollten sich
aber richtig in acht nehmen weil ja ja
nach der kurzen pause ist er bestimmt
nicht weniger streng beziehungsweise
wird noch mehr anziehen druck größer wir
freuen uns drauf
wiederholend zurück weil er ist er ist
die anderen freud sondern ich mich
persönlich kreuz und ich glaube die
ganzen scharfen sprüche die wir alle
vermisst haben im letzten jahr sind auf
jeden fall lieber daran heute ist besser
als weihnachten und geburtstag zusammen
denn endlich es dieter bohlen wieder ein
deutschland sucht den superstar dabei
ich freue mich wahnsinnig denn jeder
weiß von meinen auftritten dass ich
riesen dieter bohlen fan bin und ja
endlich ist er wieder dabei denn ich
kann deutschland sucht den superstar war
kein deutschland sucht den superstar
ohne die tat